stay hydrated stay cool no doubt your ac
is humming with this heat wave nv energy
is preparing for
another surge in demand for power as we
crank up those air conditioners even
more
the company though says it's ready to
handle the surge
hector mejia is live this morning with a
few ways that we can all
save on our power bills tell us more
about that hector
[Music]
hey there's sherry well yeah this season
usually means expensive power bills
especially if you stay indoors and crank
up that air conditioner
there are a few ways and a few programs
to help you find out how much you're
using and how to cut down on that energy
usage
first though we found out how envy
energy works to prevent rolling
blackouts here in southern nevada
the company says it takes steps
year-round including doing maintenance
and weatherizing their equipment
and just in time for this summer
upgrades were made at power plants and
also
solar and battery projects were
completed for customers
envy energy offers an online assessment
tool that lets them understand
how much energy is being used they can
also have someone come to their home
and do a home energy assessment to look
at air filters and light bulbs and
identify
additional cost saving opportunities a
lot of times customers are just
unaware of certain things that are
driving energy bills up so it's a great
service
for everybody to take advantage of
and here are a few simple things you can
do right away and keep your power bill
down
set your thermostat at a comfortable 78
degrees when you are home
bump it up to 80 or more possibly when
you leave keep the blinds closed and
don't use large appliances all at once
and you can find all the information
posted already on our website
8newsnow.com